Now what I'd like to do is show you a bunch of examples on how the change of
just the aperture itself can change the look and feel of an image.
We saw that for changes of shutter speed, where we show motion blur and
streaks of light.
Let's start off with, completely of course, a closed aperture.
Of course, I'm showing a white.
Doesn't mean it should be completely black.
There's no light entered.
But let's look at, as soon I open the aperture, what kind of images I get.
So this is an opening of f over 3.5, so the end number is 3.5.
These are my three friends again, and actually hopefully you can see this, and
we'll be putting these images up for you to look at more carefully, also online.
Much more crisper.
You can actually see the beard and stuff.
But here things start getting blurry.
In fact, my dear friend Einstein is almost out of focus here.
This effect is also sometimes known as shallow depth of field.
And sometimes it's intentionally done by photographers because they want to
focus more on the front person, and
not actually pay attention to the people behind.
So look at this, was here, of course, you can't tell much detail of this one.
Let's now start changing the aperture values.
I've closed the aperture a little bit.
Now we are at a 4.0.
Might be hard to tell but
things have gotten a little bit more in focus at the back.
Now you should be able to tell a little bit more difference here.
again, now we are 5.6, smaller aperture.
Here actually you should be able to see a little bit more detail.
We are at f/8.
Much smaller aperture.
You can actually start seeing his hair.
And Mr. Einstein has gotten a little bit more in focus.
And you can actually start seeing the vase and
all the intricacies of this vase right here.
The trees are also getting a little bit more in focus back there.
Moving to f/11, increased focus again, smaller aperture.
F/14, now here, you should be able to see a lot more detail.
Getting much and much crisper, and in fact, this is and
this is pretty much the same kinds of crispness and sharpness.
There's a little bit more blur, but let's see what we can do with that next.
But f/18, very small aperture, much more crisper,
here you actually can see the vase in more detail.
The tree, the leaves are much clearer.
And the whole thing seems to be a little bit more full and focused.
And there seems to be no, you know,
shallow depth of field kind of stuff back there.
Gone, taking it to f/22, much more crisper.
Just to help to visualize this,
I'm going to just show you three different ones here.
3.5.
Very blurry.
F/11, less blurry.
Tree is in focus.
Just switching back for you to see what it was before.
Forward, let's go one more.
F/22.
Twice.
And of course, less light is coming in, for various reasons.
Yes, we're keeping the shutter open longer, but that's not the point here.
The point is, I'm showing the effects just of this kind of stuff.
You see that this is much more in focus.
Just looking at it closely again,
next to each other, these are the two differences, wider, smaller.